les yeux bleus sous une frange rousse
elle avait frôlé l'an dernier à cannes
le prix d'adaptation pour la dentellière
un très beau film de claude goretta et
bien isabelle huppert est revenue à
cannes aujourd'hui sous les traits de
violette nozière dans le film de claude
chabrol et c'est peut-être cette année
ici que la jeune comédienne en
remportera la palme
nous allons aller tout de suite
akale j'espère le plus vite possible en
tout cas retrouver isabelle huppert
l empêchant sa pitié pour leur misère
est le crédit l'année dernière favorite
un bout de temps pendant le festival
pour la palme d'or d'interprétation
isabelle huppert repart cette année avec
violette nozière pourtant elle n'aime
guère les manifestations
cinématographiques
j'aime pas y rester trop longtemps
jouissant la fois bien et mal en ce
moment j'aimerais bien être coupé en
deux une partie de moi-même qui se voit
et puis l'autre qu'ils soient très très
loin qui regarde tout ça se passait
parce que
s'il ya des périodes comme ça on est un
peu sollicité on est un peu mise sur le
devant de la scène et puis
il faut jouer son propre rôle tout d'un
coup et moi finalement j'aime j'aime
bien jouer des rôles mais mon propre
rôle j'aime pas tellement qu'ils soient
qu'ils soient rendus publics
c'est une nouvelle affaire dreyfus la
moitié de la france votre côté des
demandes en mariage cet homme qui veut
se suicider pour vous un et groupes de
prêtres qui vous entend tout ce que je
veux c'est qu'on vient de perdre ses
pages aurait choisi autre chose à ce
moment là que des ajustements si je suis
comédienne c'est pour c'est jean dose
des costumes comme ça qui me cache bon
jusque là tu sais moi mais personne
personne ne le voit
admettons que quand tu as but et on
vieux synthés rien fait mais quand on va
te couper la tête
cinq ans même de faire quelque chose
on ne comprend pas la tête il semble que
vous avez joué la dentellière vous jouez
violette nozière vous aimiez les
personnages un peu opaque un peu un peu
inexpliquée même je dirais presque un
peu inexplicable c'est vrai j'aime bien
ce personnage comme ça qui sont pas
vraiment entrer dans la réalité qui sont
un peu comme ça à la frontière entre
l'adolescence et l'âge adulte et qui qui
sont très introverti et très très
tourner sur eux-mêmes et qui qui ont qui
vivent à peu dans l'imaginaire comme ça
je suis assez tiré par ce genre de
personnage et c'est vrai que ça s'est un
peu à deux médiateurs commun qui entre
la dentellière et et violette nozière
c'est des personnages qui n'ont pas
vraiment de de relations avec le monde
extérieur qui qui voit les choses dans
leurs rêves et d'ailleurs dans leurs
fantasmes et vous il ya un dénominateur
commun entre vous et ses personnages il
ya moi oui vous me dégoûtez le tous des
[ __ ] le pitoyable
je maudis tous autant que vous êtes
car emmener la condamner